hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from yet another elite
chess titled arena now as usual when
there's OHS titled arena we're gonna
show a game or two so this is a game
that was suggested to me by a subscriber
da do thinking for that it's a really an
exciting game and well some of you
always you know ask why are we showing
such well quick form is this is a bullet
game but these are very strong players
Daniel narrow disc a very strong
Grandmaster and magnets cross and of
course the world champion even though
it's a bullet game they will play a very
impressive game and of course tactics
will be missed as it is a bullet game
but you have time at your you know home
said your pcs or smartphones so you have
time to pause the video and try to find
any missing ideas that that will not
play it in the game so just for fun this
time I left there leeches handle there
we have it to dr. Victor Stein and
Rebecca Harris and their ratings so you
can enjoy that as well
now without further ado let's check out
this very nice game as the title
suggests it will be the Kings gambit so
II for with E 5 by by Rebecca Harris
with F 4 by Magnus the Kings gambit is
on the board and now Knight to c6 not
excepting the gambit right away but
after Knight to c3
we basically transpose into the Vienna
game and only now is DF 1 captured and
d4 by course and Josh Stein is gambit
asking black do you want to go for this
Queen to h4 check which is the oldest
question in the book when when something
like the Vienna game or the King's
gambit is played and another disky goes
for it we have Queen to h4 check and now
King Teti 2 so already a very exciting
position and there are some positions
where it's actually ok for whites to put
his King and e2 this is not one of them
but still it's a bullet game so you can
play anything with b6 Nordisk prepares
the V and cut off his light square
bishop and now a for now because the
bishop can also come to a6 and the from
there it would harass the white king a
bit too much so by playing a for Magnus
already prepares Knight b5 to block the
the bishops check and the Knight to f6
and it is of this as of this movemove 6
that we have a completely new game which
is not all that surprising since we are
having
the king's gambit with the white king
being Annie - so Knight to f3 cross and
develops a piece and it's often
something you will do when you allow
this check you want to get this Knight
to f3 move in to harass the Queen and
now black will start wasting moves with
the Queen because because of the check
on h4 first bush up to a6 check now
comes Knight to b5 and only now Queen to
h5 which ideas maybe of capturing here
on b5 as both the bishop and the Queen
now are attacking it
so Carson goes he 5 he blocks the
Queen's attacted a knight here and now
threatens to capture on f6 so here
Knights the e4 is play Knight to g4 was
also a possibility when you have some
ideas of maybe bringing the right over
to e3 after this night is let's say
maneuver not before - here - and then to
e3 but you like I said it's a bullet
game so Knights the e4 and here what do
you play here Nordisk it probably chose
this move with the ideas of winning some
material with tonight - G - Richard and
here indeed if cousin goes for something
well which allows that it would win
material but crossing just grabs the f4
pawn here so it's not a problem
and now the bishop regards the g3 square
and here we have queenside castle
another thing you could have tried
instead of this but it's like I said
it's hard to spot such things in a
bullet game white is actually winning
here and it's really odd since you know
it seems like black isn't the attack but
the knight on e4 is stranded and you can
you can win the game here but feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
beautiful idea here since you're at your
home you know you have more time you can
pause the video so do that for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
spot row of lines that were not played
in a bullet game and for those who if
you just want to enjoy the show Queen to
d3 traps the night the knight doesn't
have anywhere to go and the game is just
over now because here you are no longer
pinned here the bishop is not pinning
the night as the Queen is here so nice
the c6 check is a pretty big threat
which would check the king and win the
bishop on e6 and also there's just the
threat of of winning the night here and
even if you try something like nice to
g4 check it's not a problem it doesn't
do anything you can just give up the
rope here and after the Queen captures
only then will you go Knight c7 check
and pick up the bishop let's taking d8
Knight captures on HS on a 6 and like is
non-material and you don't really have a
good way of taking advantage you can't
capture here here you can capture here
you're just down material so what you
could do after Queens Rd 3 is maybe
played d5 but it still doesn't save you
because yes now the knight is protected
but now you get Knight captures in c7
like we said the knight is no longer
pinned King has to move and now you just
lose material and there is no good reply
here even 93 doesn't help you we get the
exact same position here Queen captures
and now what's a queen b5 you attack the
knight here Queen h6 and now you can go
Queen captures and if I would check and
black just falls apart so this was an
option here but like we said it's a
bullet game so because we are now
analyzing it you have time at home - so
we can use it for target practice Bishop
captures an f4 by Magnus
we have queenside castle Bernard its key
and now kinked III it's a beautiful move
by Magnus on pins from the Queen on pins
from the bishop and not only that the
King at e3 threatens to capture the
knight on e4 so what do you play here
and can the King even come to e4 I mean
can you survive with a king on e4 in a
bullet game it's definitely hard to say
but it's still impossible to save the
night that all the tactics that worked
on the previous move work here if d5
just eat captures on b6 and now if you
want to get the knight back to safety
now you get Knight captures on b6 which
delivers check and also threatens to win
material here so see capture son b6 or
if you want to expose the rook to some
danger and now Bishop captures in a sex
with check King c7 you're just down
material without any good counter play
here
so after King te 3 we have d6 by black
now offering this night here but first
cousin just gets rid of any any dangers
on the Queen side first Knight captures
on a7 width check Knight captures on a 7
and now Bishop captures on a sex with
check with King to b8 and only now King
capture Sonny force
here Magnus wins a piece but he still
has a king on e4 is this is displayable
how can black continue this first in our
disk egos d captures only five we have
Knight captures on e5 and now Queen to
h4 preparing g5 to win back material but
here across and plays a very nice
defense that the g5 move Queen to f3
seems like it's not stopping g5 but it
really is here in black plays g5 Magnus
head King to d3 planned because now if
you capture with the pawn or with the
Queen doesn't really matter you're just
getting checkmated Queen to b7 is mate
in one
so very nice idea by Crossan preparing
king to d3 s-sorry King to d3 so can i
play g5 and here if you can't play g5
and there's no way to win material and
there's no way to start attacking the
king
even though Carlsen skiing is an e4
you're just down a piece
so here Bishop to c5 is played here he
offers Crossin to capture on c5 the idea
is probably that if pawn captures he can
get the rope here and now the two rooks
will be will be very powerful here as
the Carlson's King is still a need for
but Crossan ignores the bishop he just
plays c3 strengthens the center and now
rook hd8 and now King to d3 cross and
starts escaping with a king and he's
still up a piece so it's not a problem
and here now by playing King to d3
Magnus is threatening mate Queen to be
seven will be checkmate
and here c6 blocking mate but it doesn't
help black here it's actually a force
mate in 4 so feel free to pause the
video once again and try to find this
very nice sequence I will give you a
couple of seconds of course even though
even though I can't not give you a
couple of seconds you can pause the
video by yourself I mean there's nothing
I'm actually allowing here but yeah for
those of you who were able to do that
congratulations you are an excellent
supporter of mates in board games and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
of course the idea is Knight captures on
c6 it's now a double check from the
bishop and from the night so when when
it's a double check the King has to move
there are no other moves
kink the a8 only move and now you can
either capture the rook or just move to
a5 to deliver yet another check I always
think it's cooler to deliver mate
without taking any unnecessary material
so
if you captured rook it's fine but 95 I
think it's just more poetic now it's
pretty much over the Queen delivers
check and you can't block with anything
you can block with this rope you can
block with this rook you can block with
the knight but whatever you do Queen
will just gobble up all the pieces and
it will be made so let's say you just
give up the rogue give up the rule give
up tonight and finally when the knight
blocks it will be captured King a seven
and queen b7 mate yeah just just a
wonderful wonderful game with a lot of
tackle with a lot of hidden tactics so
congratulations to everyone who spotted
all of them and yeah I mean now that's
why we show bullet games we can learn a
lot you know tactics wise and it's a
great opportunity to see for example the
world champion how he plays the Kings
gambit but yeah I also wanted to use
this video to give you some updates on
the chest manga that we discussed some I
believe two months ago or something like
that maybe even three months ago and on
the chest clock my application for that
for the Android regarding the manga we
are still we are making progress my
colleague is still you know honing his
drawing skills but we are we are moving
it forward and I think we will have like
a smaller skelet of the of the manga I
don't know in some three months time so
we will be presented with it of course
you will all be able to participate if
you want to with the story with the
ideas with everything that's how how I'm
how I imagined it but yeah it's still
not anywhere near near close so like I
said somewhere in three three months
time you will know more but we are you
know dealing with it and regarding the
chess clock I've been well informed by
my colleague that all of the updates
that you have emailed have been well
updated and that he now has only a few
glitches to take care of and that we
should be releasing the the full version
of the app somewhere I don't know you
know in a few days but again you will be
notified of that so don't think that all
of your emails were for nothing they
were all you know carefully read and you
know updated yeah that's pretty much it
for this game here are the standings
after this reaches titled arena
and we do have a surprise here magnus
carlsen did not win this lishus title
arena the title arena was won by ali
reza phir aaja the iranian grandmaster
really a spectacular play as you can see
below I think he won ten of his last ten
games in a row and it was just enough to
finish two points ahead of Magnus
Carlsen I don't know ever since I mean
he was always a great player but ever
since he was a cross and second along
with Daniel dubov the both of them have
been just showing amazing results I know
this is just a bullet tournament but
still it's an it's an amazing result but
he does have results you know in
classical play as well so really just
amazing stuff I think I don't think they
learned all that much I mean of course
they learned a lot during the World
Chess Championship matches they were
crossing seconds but I think just the
experience that you were there with
Magnus really really you know gives a
lot to your game and also you can see
there he finished with a performance of
3116 cross and finished with a third you
know 30 92 so very close and opera resin
in third place with 2984 but yeah I'm
very exciting and if I wasn't able to
watch the titled arena I've seen a few
games but if you have a ali reza game
that you really like from delicious
titled arena feel free to - hashtag
suggestion and i will definitely give it
a look at me and then make a video on it
if it's a very nice game so i do hope
you enjoyed it i would like to thank
actually Renata and Brendon Gillette for
a contribution to my channel thank you
what - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
I will continuing the couple Blanca Saga
the coverage of the Grand Prix and of
course checking up on your suggestions
thank you I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day